elles sont synonymes d'angoua ce qui
résonne encore dans l'esprit des
résidents de guesnain il y a un an le
bruit des hélicoptères et des militaires
lourdement armés mais brisée pendant
plus de deux semaines le silence et le
calme de ce secteur éloigné le lancement
de la communauté se retrouve alors en
plein coeur d'une vaste chasse à l'homme
pour retrouver calme et cloud 19 ans et
brian magee qui 18 ans les deux jeunes
britanno colombiens sont recherchés en
lien avec trois meurtres dans le nord de
leur province celui de lukasz parleurs
et china 10 un couple de touristes près
de new york springs le 15 juillet et le
botaniste les nordiques près de 10 ce
n'est que quatre jours plus tard
d'après les familles des fugitifs des
deux amis de longue date devait se
rendre dans cette région pour se trouver
un emploi d'été
personne ne se doutait alors qu'ils
entameraient cavale meurtrière
23 juillet 2019 les efforts de la grc
sont concentrés dans la région reggae
même pour retrouver les fugitifs leurs
véhicules incendiés retrouvé la veille
tout près de cette ville sur la nation
crie de fox river pour le maire
dégainait ces événements sont 6e réel il
semble être arrivé il y a beaucoup plus
longtemps
pendant la trêve doit in for men les
autres résidents sont sur le qui vive
ils apprennent dans les médias que dans
les derniers jours et deux fugitifs ont
été aperçues d'abord à cold lake en
alberta et ensuite amélioré quand ses
sketches au 1 rang de poursuivre leur
route vers galway à ce moment là qu
aujourd'hui nous demandent pourquoi sont
ils venus ici cela nous sommes tellement
aléatoire dans les jours qui suivent la
découverte du véhicule des fugitifs
l'armée se joint aux policiers étant de
trouver une aiguille dans une botte de
foin
leurs recherches sont effectuées dans
les forêts denses du nord du manitoba où
les nuits sont glaciales même en été des
insectes féroce et les ours cachés un
peu partout
les résidents ne s'enferment chez eux
une fausse alerte et place mène les
recherches pendant quelques jours une
centaine de kilomètres plus loin dans la
première nation de york point d
un an plus tard le traumatisme est
encore bien présent pour des résidents
des résidents me disent qu'ils seront
toujours affectées et bien des gens
verrouille maintenant leurs portes ce
qui est très inhabituel dans notre ville
un homme s'est même confié à moi des
mois après la traque qu'il dormait avec
un fusil près de lui doit une fois en
inde reconnaît cependant que la traque à
rapprocher les gens de kehl mais de la
nation crie de foxlink l aspect positif
après un événement tragique digne d'un
film
la chasse à l'homme aura capté
l'attention et causer une douleur est
allé indescriptible aux familles des
trois victimes
la traque a aussi représenté de
véritables moments d'angoissé dans
l'ouest canadien pour les résidants des
communautés qui se sont retrouvés sur la
route des fugitifs
exit est sur le chemin du retour car oui
elle a aussi marqué johan lussier demers
passionné de voyages et de camping
le 19 juillet la manitobaine et son
conjoint trouve un lieu de camping isolé
a dit cela dans le nord de la colombie
britannique
sans radio ni cellulaire le couple est
loin de s'imaginer que le corps du
botaniste les nordiques vient d'être
découvert tout près le lendemain on se
rend dans une station service
il allume la radio et apprenne la
terrible nouvelle c'est incroyable dans
tout le pays
tout le canada qui est vaste que c'est
arrivé juste à une journée différente on
s'est dit ça aurait pu facilement être
nous un surintendant de la grc déployés
sur place nous a confié qu'à plusieurs
reprises des rumeurs ont guidé les
policiers vers de fausses pistes pendant
la traque
il faut à l'avenir davantage se
concentrer sur les sources crédibles dit
il une des nombreuses leçons apprises
lors d'une chasse à l'homme qui aura
capté l'imaginaire ici patrick foucault
radio-canada winnipeg